I'm dr. Mario Livio
I'm an astrophysicist and I work here at
Space Telescope Science Institute and
I've worked here since 1991 well I would
say it's really a sort of a discovery
machine it shows us the universe it has
given us the universe if you like like
we've never seen it before one moment I
particularly remember is when we took
the Hubble Deep Field this was at the
time the deepest image of the universe
in visible light it was focused on a
blank area of the sky in the
constellation Ursa Major
it had no bright stars and it had no
bright sources of any sort it was
literally an empty area of the sky but
the telescope stared at that blank area
for about ten days and I remember
waiting for that image to come down a
few of us gathered around the computer
screen to actually see it you know as
the image was coming and you know once
that image you know was eventually
processed and so on it revealed to us
something astounding because in an area
that was you know just about the area
you would see through a drinking straw
if you looked at the sky there were like
three thousand galaxies so that was a
very powerful moment where on one hand
we saw how small we are compared to the
vastness of the cosmos on the other how
powerful in some sense we are that we
are able to actually see all this and
you know of course immediately realized
that a lot of work a lot of research
will be done on this that was really an
astounding moment
you